I promise to critically examine the
systems and experiences that impact
every person's health and ability to
receive care I vow to use this knowledge
to uplift my patience and disrupt the
injustices that harm them as I Forge the
future of medicine I promise to
self-reflect diligently to confront
unconscious prejudices and to develop
the skills knowledge and character
necessary to engender an inclusive
Equitable field of medicine let us bow
our heads in recognition of the gravity
of this Earth
okay what you just heard was a bizarre
oath to wokeness that Columbia
University Med students were asked to
take on campus now it sounded like
something you'd hear in a in a movie
about some communist regime
well imagine how shocked our next is
guest was to hear it
after defecting from North Korea to the
United States yanmi Park was excited
about starting a new life with freedom
but she also observed and experienced a
shocking Trend towards censorship here
and compulsory group think
in fact it was so chilling it reminded
her of the brutal regime she risked her
life to escape from
now when she addressed this in speeches
on college campuses across the United
States
she came immediately under attack and
faced censorship and even death threats
she explores all of this and her new
book called while time remains a North
Korean defector's search for freedom in
America human rights activist yanmi Park
joins me now yanmi
what did you say exactly that triggered
this intense reaction even death threats
yeah the things that I said how it is so
important for individuals have ability
to defend and protect themselves from
the government which means owning a gun
I always imagined when somebody does a
wrong thing in North Korea or say a one
wrong word it was going to kill up to
three to eight generations of our family
members and imagine when North Korea if
they had the guns the region would not
do that to its own people so when I came
to America I realized that Americans
have these unique rights that was given
by the Constitution that they have a
right to defend their rights from the
government of course I started on my
YouTube channel publicly and that video
got censored and from there on I was
named as a bigot racist right-winger CIA
agent paid by Fox I mean anything that
you can imagine I've been named for
now yanmi a Pew research poll this came
out last September found that Americans
with postgraduate education are most
likely to have a positive view of
socialism what does that say to you
about the quality of the American higher
education system
I'm really not surprised because when I
was starting my education as a free
person in this land of free I couldn't
believe it because the lectures the
messages that my professors were
teaching was it was exactly the same
thing that my North Korean teachers told
me houses exactly the same so basically
yeah in in North Korea they say all the
problems that we have is because of the
greedy capitalists because of American
imperialists and when I come to Columbia
University they say the exact same thing
that all the problems that we have in
this world is because of the white men
and the greedy capitalism and therefore
we need to dismantle the system destroy
this country in the name of equity that
brought my home country into what it is
which is modern day Holocaust
I want Americans across the country to
understand how important it is that
you're delivering this message in your
book and on the angle tonight
and in North Korea they teach children
to hate the United States they ridicule
our constitution our founding they
basically call all of America racist you
go to Colombia
and you find the same thoughts expressed
there by academic leaders correct I
don't even know what happened to America
I only came here eight years ago but as
a child I mean I'm a mother I'm raising
a child in this country and I'm so
worthy because the first thing that my
mother taught me as a young girl was
don't even whisper because the birds and
mice could hear me she said my tongue
was the most dangerous thing that I had
in my body because I couldn't say the
wrong thing
in America now of course we are not
putting them the fighting Squad but if
you say the one wrong thing your
livelihood is lost your dignity is going
away and you're forever marked and even
my son who who was only two years old
and some parents noticed that I was open
I guess or conservative they would tell
their children that don't play with my
son
because it's a child of bigot
we punished family members for
somebody's political opinion and when I
became American citizen last year my
interview asked me have you ever
persecuted anybody for their political
opinion if I said yes I could not become
American so the people forgot what it
means to be American in this country
well I think when you ask people today
what does it mean to be an American a
lot of young people get so many mixed
messages in school the the instinct to
say America's Freedom it's liberty it's
a right to speak your mind it's a right
to self-defense I mean that doesn't come
to mind because it's under attack
relentlessly on me your book is so
important uh I think of all the uh
people would love freedom freedom to
speak out in North Korea tonight and how
we're blessed to have you in this
country need more people like you yanmi
thank you very much for writing this
book and thank you for having the
courage to speak out and not be afraid
we really appreciate you
thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else